Let's talk turkey.
Where is the decision that happens privately
between you two of,
"We love our show, next, bigger, more,"
what is that moment?
Oh my gosh, Jo, you got the thoughts?
I think sometimes we have to go
so backwards in our remembering.
For us, we were naive.
We said yes to a show.
We actually didn't know what it was gonna turn into.
We really thought just Waco was gonna watch it
and our parents were gonna be proud.
We didn't know it was gonna go beyond Waco.
So we stepped into something.
And then, the whirlwind happened from like 2013
to, you know, five years.
We look back and we didn't remember what happened.
And yet, when is the moment that you go, "We love this,
we want our own network"?
I think when you understand the why and the intention,
and then we say we can become passionate about that.
We have said no to so many things.
But the things we say yes to
is because is it aligns with our vision
on what we want to create here on Earth.
So what did the network align with your vision and goals?
We want to highlight beautiful humans
that are doing things they're passionate about.
There's no script, there's no plan.
It's "Hey, can we step into your world
and highlight what you're doing
to make it a more beautiful place?"
Whether that's in food, home,
helping people with their weight,
and their fitness, and wellbeing, it doesn't matter.
It's just, "I love what you're doing.
Can we highlight like this?"
And so that's how we've built the network.
And to hear that from you is so wonderful,
because it's so in keeping with the good intention.
But it is amazing and an important lesson
that you can stay so well intented
and grow to infinite heights.
And may that be the takeaway?
And you've been so giving of yourselves,
what is one thing that would really shock people about you,
or at least surprise and delight,
that we don't know about you?
All right, let's go.
JoJo is a wild woman when you turn off the lights.
No!
I'm saying.
A real cat in the sack?
She's a real cat in the sack.
What are you talking about?
I'm just saying, when you turn down the lights,
she explodes in energy.
But that's not
what she was asking.
Or was it?
Oh.
No, God, help me.
Okay, so you're naughty.
I love this, and a real tomcat in the sack.
Or chick.
Oh my gosh.
See, that's gonna be the headline,
"Jo cat in a what?"
I love it.
Let's go!
Cat in the sack, oh shoot.
Love swing!
Let's go!
By the way, the cat in the sack
could be a good name for the love swing.
I love you, dad.
The swinger.
Chip, last question.
What would shock us about you?
Is there a quick thought?
First of all, chip is you see what you get.
So there's not a lot, people see so many different.
There's not a whole lot of secret layered onion.
But I will say he is so thoughtful.
He wants to connect so much.
Oh, now this is true.
I think a lot of people think he's like a guy's guy.
Jo and I are like opposites.
Every morning,
it's just sitting there going, "Are you gonna wake up?
I've got stuff to say."
I've got your coffee,
you wanna talk.
He's like trying to get me to touch those feelings
that are way deep down inside.
And I'm just tired, and I don't wanna find them yet.
So Chip is such a,
he's such a sweet.
So he's like really like he's destructive,
and he does all the things that people see him do.
But he's got this little, bitty boy heart
that is so sensitive and so thoughtful.
He's like the biggest oxymoron to me.
He's the toughest guy I know, but the softest guy I know.
And sometimes I just wanna snuggle.
And he loves to snuggle.
And only cat in the sack,
cat in the sack, you know they don't snuggle.
They pounce.
Also, Chip, could you
just do me a favor and tell men,
"Don't play the game of chicken,
and call the girl"?
Yes, call the girl.
Just call the girl.
Thank you, Chip and Joanna.
(upbeat music)